you have to pay attention to your life
because it is speaking to you all the
time and the bumps in the road and the
failures that pointed me in a New
Direction and led me to a path made
clear that is what I'm wishing for you
today your own path made clear and I
know that there is a lot of anxiety a
lot about what the future holds and how
much money you're going to make
but your anxiety does not contribute one
iota to your progress I'm here to tell
you it does the opposite look at how
many times you worried and you were
upset and you didn't think you were
going to make it through the block got
that text a couple months ago
and here you are today
you made it and I'm here to tell you
that you're going to be more than okay
so take a deep breath
with me right now
and repeat this everything is always
working out for me I want to hear it
everything is always working out for me
that's my Mantra make it yours
because it is and it has and it will
continue to be as you forge and discover
your own path need motivation watch a
top 10 with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Oprah Winfrey and my take on
her top 10 was a success enjoy
rule number two Let Excellence beat your
brand always do the right thing
always
[Applause]
be excellent
people notice
think of how you notice you go to Taco
Bell somebody gives you extra napkin and
some sauce
you notice
you want to go back to that person
because even at Taco Bell
Excellence shows itself be excellent
let Excellence be your brand
everybody talks about building a brand I
never even knew what that was
when people say you're a brand I would
say no I'm just Oprah
what I recognize now is that my choice
to in every way
in every example in every experience
to do the right thing and the excellent
thing is what has created the brand
years ago I did an ad for Revlon for uh
for an ad they were doing called
Unforgettable women
and what I know is that when you are
excellent
you become Unforgettable
people remember you you stand out
regardless of what it is you become an
unforgettable woman and that is what we
all want we want to be Unforgettable and
not forgettable
so doing the right thing even
when nobody knows you're doing the right
thing
will always bring the right thing to you
I promise you that why because the third
law of motion is always at work for
every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction
that is so true in all of our lives
that's what Newton said
Celie in The Color Purple said it
everything you even try to do to me
already done to you
so you don't have to worry about revenge
or
getting back at somebody
making sure they pay
you just have to do the right thing and
the right thing will follow you even
when people don't support it rule number
three serve the world you say to life
you ask this question everybody who is
still exploring where to go next you ask
the question
how can I
be used
life use me use me show me through my
talents and my gifts show me through
what I know what I need to know what I
have yet to learn how to be used in the
greater service to life you ask that
question and I guarantee you smithy's
the answer will be returned and rewarded
to you with fulfillment
which is really the major definition of
success for me
question how can I be used and then get
still enough for the answer because what
I've discovered in all of my years of
conversations and interviews with people
anytime you have to go and ask everybody
else what is the answer to a question it
means you haven't gotten still enough
yourself to quiet out the noise of the
world to listen to your inner GPS your
inner guidance that always knows that
knows right now what is the best next
right thing for you to do
it's your calling to serve because you
are a woman of the world and whatever
your chosen field I know this that when
you shift the Paradigm to how can I be
you
be you how can I use my art by painting
my music
by medical skills how can I use my
listening My caring in service to that
which is greater than myself you shift
the Paradigm to service and the reward
comes rule number four take small steps
daily I'm here to tell you that you
actually do get to transform the world
every day by your actions
small steps lead to Big accomplishments
and I'm here to tell you that your life
is in some big break like everybody
thinks it is they're waiting on the big
break it's actually about taking one
significant life transforming step at a
time so you can pick a problem literally
any problem the list is long because
there's gun violence and economic
inequality and there's media bias in the
homeless need opportunity and The
Addictive need treatment and the
dreamers need protection the prison
system needs to be reformed the social
safety net needs saving misogyny needs
to stop
and the truth is you cannot fix
everything but what you can do here and
now is make a decision because life is
about decisions and the decision is that
you will
use your life in service you will be in
service to life and you will speak up
you will show up you will stand up you
will sit in you will volunteer you will
vote you will shout out you will help
you will lend a hand you will offer your
talent and your kindness however you can
and you will radically transform
whatever moment you're in which leads to
bigger moments also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five be still and listen I
wish I could tell you I know the path
forward I don't there is so much
uncertainty in truth there always has
been what I do know is that the same
guts and Imagination that got you to
this moment all those things are the
very things that are going to sustain
you through whatever is coming it's
vital that you learn and we all learn to
be at peace with the discomfort of
stepping into the unknown it's really
okay to not have all the answers the
answers will come for sure if you can
accept not knowing long enough to get
still and stay still long enough for new
thoughts to take root in your more quiet
deeper truer self the noise of the world
drowns out the sound of you you have to
get still to listen so can you use this
disorder that covid-19 has wrought can
you treat it as an Uninvited Guest
that's come into our midst to reorder
our way of being can you the class 2020
is back together again but how to create
a new and more evolved normal a world
more just kind beautiful tender luminous
creative whole we we need you to do this
because the pandemic has illuminated the
vast systemic inequities that have
Divine Life for too many for too long
for poor communities without adequate
Access to Health Care inequality is a
pre-existing condition for immigrant
communities forced to hide in the
shadows inequality is a pre-existing
condition for incarcerated people with
no ability to social distance inequality
is a pre-existing condition for every
person burdened by bias and bigotry for
every black man and woman living in
their American skin fearful to even go
for a jog inequality is a pre-existing
condition
you have the power to stand for to fight
for and vote for healthier conditions
that will create a healthier Society
this moment is your invitation to use
your education to begin to heal our
afflictions by applying the best of what
you've learned in your head and felt in
your heart rule number six make sure you
are heard every person just wants to
know they were heard
every argument you have with your
friends is not about whatever it is
you're arguing about it's ultimately
about do you hear me
and many of you have even said when you
don't feel you're being hurt can you
just hear me
can you hear me can you see me and could
you understand
that what I'm saying to you actually
matters and I have found that no matter
what the conversation of the
confrontation or the experience if you
can mirror back to that person yes I
hear you and this is what you're saying
whether you choose to do it or not just
being heard makes all the difference
being validated because everybody wants
to be heard rule number seven just be
yourself Jack Canfield
Chicken Soup for the Soul another one of
my thought leaders that I admire says
the greatest wound we've all experienced
is somehow being rejected for being our
authentic self and as a result of that
we then try to be what we're not to get
approval love protection safety money
whatever that is and the real need for
all of us really is to reconnect with
the essence of who we really are we own
all the disowned parts of ourselves
whether it's our emotions our
spirituality whatever we all go around
hiding parts of ourselves he says he was
with a Buddhist teacher a number of
years ago and that teacher said
here's the secret if you were to
meditate for 20 years this is where
you'd finally get to just be your self
but be all of you
so I've made a living
not a living
but a real life
from being true to myself
using the energy of my personality to
actually serve the purpose of my soul
and that purpose I'm here to tell you
gets revealed to you daily it is not
just one thing it is the thread that is
connecting the dots of everything that
you do so when I first started
television at 19 as I said I was just
happy to have a job but later through
experience trial error some failures
recognize that my true purpose was to be
an inspiration and a Force for good to
allow people to see the best of
themselves through the work and the
stories that we were able to tell
and so
that becomes my legacy rule number eight
discover your purpose if humanity is a
global body every soul is a cell in that
body and we are being challenged as
never before to keep the global body
healthy by keeping ourselves healthy and
mind and body and spirit as all the
Traditions affirm the deepest self-care
is at once caring for the Human family
and we see this so clearly with
essential workers look who turns out to
be essential teachers your teachers
healthcare workers of course the people
stocking grocery shelves the cashiers
the truck drivers food providers those
who are caring for your grandparents
those who clean the places where we work
and shop and carry out our daily lives
we are all here because they at Great
and profound risk are still providing
their essential service
what will your essential service be
what really matters to you the fact that
you're alive means you've been given a
reprieve to think deeply about that
question how will you use what matters
in service to yourselves your community
and the world for me it's always been
talking and sharing stories for you well
that's for you to discover and my hope
is that you will harness your education
your creativity and your Valor your
voice your vote reflecting on all that
you've witnessed and hungered for all
that you know to be true and use it to
create more equity
Equity Justice and joy in the world rule
number nine know who you are knowing who
you are
knowing who you are
being able to answer this question
who am I
and what do I want
you know many times when I go out of the
country I am baffled by that question
to explain what is your occupation I've
I've stood there for 10 minutes well am
I talk show host well I'm more than a
talk show host
and my business woman I'm business woman
I'm more than a businesswoman am I an
entrepreneur I'm more an entrepreneur so
I just leave it blank or self-employed
[Music]
so I'm not asking for the roles that you
play as daughters I'm not asking
that question what are the roles that
you play as a daughter as a friend as a
sister you're going to be a lawyer
you're going to teach you're going to be
a pharmacist
I'm asking the bigger question of who am
I
who am I really
my answer is I am God's child
I am
I am that which is born of all that is
I am as Pia de Chardon said a spiritual
being having a human experience
come trailing the breath of the
ancestors yet but trailing the breath of
the angels and understanding that
because I am connected to the source of
all that is
all that is possible is possible for me
that's who I am
and what do I want
I don't want to just be
successful in the world
I don't want to just
make a Mark or have a legacy
the answer to that question for me is I
want to fulfill the highest
truest
expression
of myself as a human being
I want to fulfill the promise that the
Creator
dreamed when he dreamed the cells that
made up me
what do I want
you must have some kind of vision for
your life
even if you don't know the plan you have
to have a direction in which you choose
to go
I never was the kind of woman who liked
to get in a car and just go for a ride
I had a boyfriend would say let's just
go for a ride
I want to know where are we going
do we have a destination is there a plan
are we just riding
what I've learned is that it's a great
metaphor for life
you want to be in the driver's seat of
your own life because if you're not life
will drive you
so
knowing who you really are
in this space and time that we embody
and Rule Number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is speak
the truth what I learned going to beauty
salon and asking them after the news
director had told me that my hair was
too thick and my eyes were too far apart
and I needed a makeover and um sitting
in a beauty salon in a French beauty
salon allowing them to put a French perm
on my black hair
and having the perm burned through my
cerebral cortex
woman that I am now so not having the
courage to say this is burning me
a week later
born you're black and a woman involved
and trying to be an anchor woman
you look
you learn you're not Diana Ross
that you're not Barbara Walters trying
to be I was at the time I had a lot of
lessons I remember going on the air many
times and not reading my copy ahead of
time and I was on the air one night and
ran across the word b-a-r-b-a-d-o-s that
may be Barbados to you but it was
Barbados to me that night
and telling the story as an anchor woman
about a vote in absentia California I
thought it was
located near San Francisco
and one of the worst one of the worst
this is when I broke out of my barber
shell because I'm sitting there crossing
my legs trying to talk like Barbara be
like Barbara and uh I was reading a
story about someone with a blaze
attitude which
and I started to laugh at myself on the
air and broke through my Barbara shell
and had decided on that day that
laughing was okay even though Barbara
hadn't at that time
and it was through my series of mistakes
that I learned that I could be a better
Oprah than I could be a better Barber
and I allowed Barbara to be the mentor
for me as she always has been and I
decided then to try to pursue the idea
of being myself and I am just thrilled
that I get paid so much every day for
just just being myself but it was a
lesson long in coming recognizing that I
had the Instinct that the inner voice
that told me that you need to try to
find a way to answer to your own truth
was the voice I needed to be still and
listen to get this this just remember
this because this will happen many times
in your life when people show you who
they are believe them the first time
not the 29th time
[Applause]
that's particularly good when it comes
to to men situations because when he
doesn't call back the first time
when you're mistreated the first time
when you see someone who shows you a
lack of Integrity or dishonesty the
first time know that that will be
followed by many many many other times
that will at some point in life come
back to haunt or hurt you when people
show you who they are believe them the
first time live your life from a point
of view of truth and you will
live your life from truth and you will
survive everything everything I believe
even death
you will survive everything if you can
live your life from a point of view of
Truth
all of you know the story of how this
great school came to be how the
stanfords lost their only child to
typhoid at the age of 15. they had every
right and they had every reason to turn
their backs against the world at that
time but instead they they channeled
their grief and their pain into an act
of Grace
within a year of their son's death they
made the founding grant for this great
school pledging to do for other people's
children what they were not able to do
for their own boy
the lesson here is clear and that is if
you're hurting you need to help somebody
else ease their hurt
if you're in pain help somebody else's
pain and when you're in a mess you get
yourself out of the mess helping
somebody out of theirs and in the
process you get to become a member of
what I call the greatest Fellowship of
all the sorority of compassion and the
fraternity of service
suffered the worst thing any any
mom and dad can ever endure yet they
understood that helping others is the
way we help ourselves and this wisdom is
increasingly supported by scientific and
sociological research it's no longer
just woo-woo soft skills talk
there's actually a helper's high a
spiritual surge again from serving
others so if you want to feel good you
have to go out and do some good
but when you do good I hope you strive
for more than just the good feeling that
service provides because I know this for
sure that doing good actually makes you
better
so whatever field you choose
if you operate from the Paradigm of
service
I know your life will have more value
and you will be happy
I was always happy doing my talk show
but that happiness reached a depth of of
uh of fulfillment
of uh of joy that I really can't
describe to you a measure when I stopped
just being on TV and looking at TV as a
job and decided to use television to use
it and not have it use me to use it as a
platform to serve my viewers that alone
changed the trajectory of My Success
so I know this that whether you're an
actor you offer your talent in the way
that most inspires art if you're an
anatomist you look at your your gift as
knowledge
and service to Healing having compassion
for other people is at the top of that
list
I would say commitment is at the top of
that list and also a spirit of
constructive engagement and by
compassion I don't just mean sympathy it
certainly isn't pity it's being present
and it's also feeling with other beings
you know during the years of the Oprah
show I interviewed over 37 000 people
one on one
so whenever I'm telling my girls
anything and they say oh they start
rolling their eyes I go
I'm the only person you're going to talk
to is talk 37 000 people
so if I were you I would pay attention
but during all those years of talking to
over 37 000 people one on one
I could feel what they were feeling so
strongly sometimes it made me sick
literally
so I had to learn how to feel how others
were feeling feel with others which it
is which is what it means to be
compassionate to feel with others
without taking in all of their stuff
being compassionate means I feel with
you it is one of the greatest qualities
in the world to have if you're going to
be uh majoring in what it takes to be a
great human being I feel with you means
I not only am willing to walk in your
shoes
it means my heart beats with yours
it means I see myself in you it means I
may not have shared that circumstance
but I know what heartbreak feels like I
know what pain feels like and all pain
is the same it means I can feel your
will to want to do better and be better
and I feel and I am with you in spite of
everything that's happened to you I feel
your need to rise I want to help you
rise I want to rise with you if you can
capture the humanity of people
if you can just capture the humanity of
the people of the stories that you're
telling you then get that much closer to
your own humanity and you can confront
your bias and you can build your
credibility and hone your instincts and
compound your compassion you can use
your gifts that's what you're really
here to do to illuminate
the darkness in our world so many people
are worried about building a brand I
hear kids on social media talking about
their brand and I used to really resent
the word when people would say to me oh
you have this brand because I never
never even thought about a brand I just
thought about day in and day out making
the best right choice for me but now I
embrace it because I recognize people
see me as a brand
but for me it's not a business it is a
question of what do you stand for and I
will say this you're nothing if you're
not the truth
so I have made
I've made a living
I've made a living I've made a life made
a fortune really it's fantastic
all good
from being true to myself
and and that's the if I could leave you
with any message today that is it uh the
biggest reward is not Financial benefits
though it's really good you can get a
lot of great shoes
nothing wrong with great shoes
but those of you who have a lot of shoes
know that having great shoes and a
closet full of shoes or cars or houses
or square footage doesn't fill up your
life
it doesn't
but living a life of substance can
substance through your service your
offering of your whole self and the
Baseline for how do you live a life of
substance is whatever is the truth for
you what do you stand for the problem is
everybody is meeting hysteria with more
hysteria and then we just are all
becoming hysterical and it's getting
worse
what I've learned all these years is
that we're not supposed to match it or
even get locked into resisting or
pushing against it we're supposed to see
this moment in time for what it is we're
supposed to see through it and then
transcend it that is how you overcome
Hysteria
and that is how you overcome the sniping
at one another the trolling the
mean-spirited partisanship on both sides
of the aisle the divisiveness the
injustices and the out and out hatred
you use it
use this moment to encourage you to
embolden you and to literally push you
into the rising of your life
and to borrow a phrase from my beloved
Mentor Maya Angelou just like moons and
like Suns with the certainty of Tides
just like the Hope springing High you
will rise people may not remember your
every word
they may not remember all of your
actions but they certainly remember how
your words and your actions made them
feel
so let's leave here today
with the collective memory
of wanting to create Enlightenment in
the world
let's leave here knowing that we can
give people the sense that they have
been heard and respected
let's Foster original thinking
and Humane treatment
let's seek out the words we don't know
let's do away with the US and them I've
seen us and Them create a whole lot of
problems but I've never seen it solve
one thing instead let's nourish our
artists let's offer the possibility of
something better for all of us
because a new day is no longer on the
horizon the new day is now nobody's
journey is seamless or smooth we all
stumble we all have setbacks if things
go wrong you hit a dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying time to
change course
so ask every failure this is what I do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time I say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson you
get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what I found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
Life's whisper
because life always Whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
Whispers sooner or later you'll get a
scream whatever your resist persists but
if you ask the right question not why is
this happening but what is this here to
teach me what is this here to teach me
it puts you in the place and space to
get the lesson you need my friend
Eckhart Tolle who's written this
wonderful book called A New Earth
it's all about letting the awareness of
who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from The
Challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
Hennessy said I started this school
in Africa
and
I founded the school where I'm trying to
give South African girls a shot at a
future like yours Stanford
and I spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students I wanted every girl to feel her
worth reflected in her surroundings so I
checked every blueprint I picked every
pillow I was looking at the grout in
between the bricks I knew every thread
count of the sheets I chose every girl
from The Villages from nine provinces
and yet last fall I was faced with a
crisis I'd never anticipated I was told
that one of the dorm matrons was
suspected of sexual abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first I cried actually I sobbed for
about a half an hour and then I said
let's get to it that's all you get is a
half an hour you need to focus on the
now what you need to do now so I
contacted a child trauma specialist I
put together a team of investigators I
made sure the girls had counseling and
support and Gail and I got on a plane
and flew to South Africa and the whole
time I kept asking that question what is
this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been I got a lot of lessons I understand
now the mistakes I made because I had
been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
I built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out so it's a lesson that applies to all
of our Lives as a whole what matters
most is what's inside what matters most
is the sense of Integrity of quality and
Beauty I got that lesson and what I know
is is that the girls came away with
something too they've emerged from this
more resilient and knowing that their
voices have power I think some people
think that or under the impression that
I was born empowered that I was born
coming out of the womb ready to
interview a klansman
then cut to commercial we'll be right
back
but the truth is I know very well what
it's like to be marginalized to be told
either subtly or quite directly that my
contribution isn't or wasn't welcome
that my face was invisible and that my
needs were an affront so back when I was
doing the news in Baltimore I asked to
be paid the same as my co-anchor who did
exactly the same job as I was doing and
I
expected that I would be compensated so
I went in and I asked that I would get
the same amount of money so he was doing
the same job I was doing except that he
called me babe all the time babe yeah
babe anyway I was told by my news
director and by the general manager
because first I went the news director
then I went general manager and I was
told that because I was a single woman
who didn't have a mortgage and I didn't
have kids that I was not entitled to
earn the same kind of money as the man
who was sitting next to me doing the
same thing and I realized in that moment
that my employers did not get it they
did not understand my value
but you know what I did
so cut to AM Chicago the team's hard at
work and they had been working for a
long time
and after a year or so we were asked to
be syndicated that work began to pay off
and before long we were now no longer
called am Chicago where the national
Oprah Winfrey Show I got a raise this is
before I own myself
so
I got a raise
but my producers did not so I went into
the boss at the time
and I asked that my producers who
incidentally were all female I asked
that they would be given a pay raise
increase and my boss this is in 1986
said why
they're only girls
what do they need more money for
girls
uh I've used the word affectionately
sometimes referring to women as girls
and there was no affection in his tone
it was absolutely condescending so
uh you know it takes a while to develop
a voice but once you have it you damn
sure better use it on stuff that matters
so I took a deep breath in that moment
and said either they're going to get
raises or I'm gonna sit down
I'm not going to work if they don't get
paid more babe
now
I would like to believe that I could
have spoken that kind of Truth to
misogyny even if I'd been all by myself
but here I was on the brink of finally
getting what I really wanted and had
been working uh many years for a
national show
I mean I might have been too intimidated
to stand my own ground against this guy
if I were actually alone but here's the
thing you're never alone
you're never alone
Sovereign sound of Maya Angelou's voice
was pushing me forward that day
Whispering I come as one
but I stand as ten thousand
so when I was faced with the opportunity
to advocate for my producers I silently
called on some of the ten thousand
and walked into my boss's office hand in
spirit with the women who had come
before me
I could feel Bessie Smith
and Billie Holiday and Ella Fitzgerald
and Pearl Bailey and Sarah Vaughn and
Lena horn clutching their Green books
looking for a place to eat while they
sang in supper clubs for whites only
and I could feel Reese Taylor and Rosa
Parks refusing to relinquish their
dignity in the face of death threats all
these women were with me that day
walking into the office in Chicago as
was Diana Carroll and Petula Clark and
Joan Baez and Mary Tyler Moore and Moms
Mabley and Barbara Walters and all of
the astonishing women whose names none
of us will ever even know despite their
sacrifice and I'm pretty sure I even
heard Shirley Chisholm
urging me on with this thought
if they don't give you a seat at the
table bring a folding chair
[Applause]
[Music]
and I understood
I understood that there were so many
times that many women from my mother's
generation and God knows my
grandmother's generation who were forced
to grit their teeth and just take it
because standing up for themselves
wasn't even an option the risk was too
great and they knew it but they also
knew in their bones what my dear friend
Maya put so eloquently into words when
she says you may not control all the
events that happened to you but you can
decide not to be reduced by them
because these women and so many others
like them made the decision not to allow
themselves to be reduced by the many
injustices they were subjected to I
found the strength to act if not just
for myself not just for my producers but
for all the women who in their ingenious
ways subverted the rules laid the
foundation and pushed the envelope just
a little bit further for me for me I've
already made more money than I expected
I've already got more shoes than I know
and I'm like okay what to do with the
shoes you know so and it never was about
material possessions I don't think if I
could have um if I'd sat down
and said how do I dream myself up to be
able to get all this I wouldn't have
known how to do it so I was driven by a
passion that was bigger than the show in
the beginning and I believe that in
order to continue every person has a
responsibility to use their life
you everybody who came here today your
life may not be as big as mine meaning
not as many people know you and the only
difference between being famous and not
is that more people know your name the
real reality is what Billy was singing
and what
um Maddie talks about in his poetry is
that we are really all alike except our
hair we are really we are really all
alike and that has been one of the
greatest lessons I've learned in doing
this television show is that what
everybody is looking for is validation
yeah in every experience people are
looking to know that they matter that
you matter that I matter in every
encounter in all of your fights at home
all your arguments with your boss or
with your children with your husband
when you really peel back the layers and
get down to what is what is this what
are we arguing about you're arguing you
want to say I matter and I think that
um
what we've been able to do on this show
is to help people see that for
themselves and if I can be able to give
that back to people in a way that makes
them matter to themselves then this is
worth
millions of dollars
it's Priceless it's Priceless to be able
to do that I know exactly the moment I
started to feel valued and for me it was
school I wanted to be a fourth grade
teacher because of Mrs Duncan and I
haven't seen Mrs Duncan since then and
Mrs Duncan is here today
Johnson
the moment I felt the most value was in
my fourth grade class when Mrs Duncan
said to be I I was the one who was
chosen to lead the class and whatever it
was so what was I like I don't I don't
really remember I do remember you I
remember you were
a class full of students like Oprah I
would have been floating on air Mrs
Duncan instilled in me this sense of
believing that I mattered and that is
what every human being is looking for
when you first heard that I had like
done something in life were you did you
know that it was me yes I kept it with
you without your being aware of it and
it was Mrs Duncan who helped heal you
for me yes it was Mrs Duncan and then it
was my my sixth grade teacher Mr Graham
it was school that made me feel a sense
of value and connection
he learned a lot on this story oh I
learned a lot on the story the story was
life-changing for me life-changing
really life changing and people use that
word rhetorically life changing it's
changed the way I operate with in my
business with my people with my school
one two three
you say that the most important question
to ask of people who have gone through
trauma is not what's wrong with you but
what happened to you yeah yeah yeah so
when you see you know a church being
shot up or you see you know all of the
headline-making uh stories of people
seemingly gone mad your first thought is
what happened to that person right right
you know what has been life changing for
me
um is the question what happened to you
not what is wrong with you but what
happened to you which is an important
question not just for people who have
been so-called traumatized but it's the
most important question you can ask of
anyone I can say that of all the stories
I've ever done in my life and all of the
experiences I've ever had and people
I've interviewed this story has had more
impact on me than practically anything
I've ever done
change the way you see everyone it's
changed the way I see everyone so when I
have an employee who is acting out of
line or who is just being a jerk I don't
think what's wrong with that guy
what's wrong with that girl what's wrong
with that I think I wonder what happened
to them I wonder what happened to them I
wonder what happened that caused them to
behave that way that's what the story
did for me before we came here Deepak
Chopra
great thought leader of our times I had
called him wanting to do an interview
with him and he said he was going to be
coming to India and I I have a vision
board I keep a vision board first vision
board ever ever started was to get
Barack Obama elected so I just had
Barack Obama
and then I went back
and that vision board was right by my
in my bathroom by the bathtub so every
morning I would say Barack Obama
President Barack Obama president
and then uh this is in 2007 and then I
decided I had to go back and put 2008 so
that whoever was listening would know I
didn't mean Barack Obama president 2012
or 2016. so I only had that as a vision
and then I put a picture after Barack
Obama won
I put a picture I cut out of a magazine
of a woman on a camel
in and it said come to India foreign
come to India and I've held that as my
vision on my vision board for the past
three years so when this idea of coming
with Deepak I went now it's time to
fulfill the vision so first impression
coming in the city chaotic and then
being in the city with more people than
I've ever encountered in my life
but still feeling not a sense of being
unsafe I wanted to share with you this
line from brene Brown's latest
extraordinary new book Atlas of the
heart that will be available come this
Tuesday
um November 30th she says our connection
with others can only be as deep as our
connection with ourselves
that's what we're talking about this
week
and there perhaps is no time in recent
memory when it's more necessary to
actually cultivate empathy and
connection in order to make sense of the
profound changes that we're all
undergoing we just everywhere we turn we
can't grapple with the many urgent
issues facing us and facing our planet
without understanding ourselves first
and in atlas of the heart Renee and her
team of researchers and therapists and
Educators and others have so richly
explored how to cultivate an emotional
vocabulary like we need the words the
language the Expressions that help us
process and identify what it is we're
feeling and what is happening to us and
to be able to communicate that to other
people and what they've discovered is
that without that we won't find the
Solid Ground within us that gives us the
courage and the confidence to embrace
love to embrace happiness and our own
vulnerability to face and transcend our
pains or to navigate the great
uncertainty that is The Human Condition
so in brene's word she says with an
adventurous heart and the right Maps we
can travel anywhere and never fear
losing ourselves even when we don't know
where we are I just love that the Solid
Ground the anger we're searching for is
connection and it is within each of us
but to forge meaningful connections with
others
again we have to first connect with
ourselves and I know we're doing a lot
of connecting this week with family and
friends we have to establish a common
understanding of the language of
emotions and Human Experience in order
to do that here are variations on a few
grand themes beginning with this pick a
problem any problem the list is long
here are just a few that are at the top
of my list there's gun violence and
there's climate change and systemic
racism economic inequality media bias
the homeless need opportunity the
addicted need treatment the dreamers
need protection the prison system needs
reforming the lgbtq community
the lgbtq community needs acceptance
the social safety net needs saving and
the misogyny needs to stop
[Applause]
needs to stop
but you can't fix everything
and you can't save every soul but what
can you do
here and now I believe you have to
declare war on one of our most dangerous
enemies and that is cynicism because
when that little creature sinks in its
hooks into you it'll Cloud your Clarity
it'll compromise your integrity it'll
lower your standards it'll choke your
empathy and sooner or later
cynicism shatters your faith
when you hear yourself saying ah it
doesn't matter what one person says oh
well so what it's not going to make any
difference what I do who cares when you
hear yourself saying that know that
you're on a collision course for our
culture
and I understand how it's so easy to
become disillusioned so tempting to
allow apathy to set in because anxiety
is being broadcast on 157 channels 24
hours a day all night long
and everybody I know is feeling it but
these times
these times are here to let us know that
we need to take a stand for our right to
have hope and we need to take a stand
with every ounce of wit and courage we
can muster the question is what are you
willing to stand for that question is
going to follow you throughout your life
and here's how you answer it
you put your honor
where your mouth is
put your honor where your mouth is when
you give your word keep it
show up do the work get your hands dirty
and then you'll begin to draw strength
from the understanding the true knowing
that history is still being written
you're writing it every day
The Wills still in spin and what you do
or what you don't do will be a part of
it let failure be your friend
there are going to be times of course
where you're going to win a lot a lot of
things are going to go your way
and it's wonderful to bask in that
adulation and to feel proud of your
successes but they're also going to be
times the satisfaction that those
moments bring nothing can compare to
that those victories will feed you for
years to come and help you stay
committed when your tank is sometimes
empty winning is great it's fantastic I
love it I love being number one I love
winning
but it's the times when things go wrong
when you fall or fail that you're
actually gone going to learn the most
about yourself
you know all those years on the Oprah
show 25 years we were the number one
show for 25 years and that's because I
lived with the intention to serve the
audience the audience came first every
show I would sit with the producers and
say well I can't do that because I can't
find the truth of myself in that show I
have to have a thread of Truth to be
able to hold on to so I knew so well the
audience I felt like I was the audience
the audience
um was me and I felt so connected and
then I ended that and started a new
network
and I flailed for a while
and I was really upset with myself
but I will tell you that when I was able
to shift the Paradigm to start to
looking at wow what I have instead of
what I don't have what I have instead of
what I thought I'd lost I was able to
begin to turn things around but it's
those moments of being of uncertainty
it's the moments where you know all of
my mistakes show up on the Evening News
you can make a mistake I can tell if
I've done something wrong it's on the
CNN crawl I can read about it
but learning from the moments where
things weren't going so great
being able to get still to connect with
that which I know is God the force the
power greater than myself and to come
back and realize that in order to move
forward you move forward by taking the
next right step you don't have to know
everything to do you don't have to know
all the steps to make just what is the
next right move it's true you can't
personally stop anybody from walking
into a school with an assault rifle nor
can you single-handedly ensure that the
rights that your mothers and your
grandmothers fought so hard for will be
preserved for the daughters that you may
someday have
and it'll take more than you alone to
pull 40 million Americans out of poverty
but who will you be if you don't care
enough to try and what mountains could
we move I think what gridlock could we
eradicate if we were to join forces and
work together in service of something
greater than ourselves you know my
deepest satisfaction and my biggest
rewards have come from exactly that
pick a problem
any problem
and do something about it because to
somebody who's hurting
something is everything as you're trying
to figure out what do I do how should I
do it first of all I will say this that
when you don't know what to do my girls
have heard this over a hundred times
when you don't know what to do you do
nothing you get still until you do know
because when you have to ask everybody
else should I should I should I do this
should I should have and that's whether
it's buying a pair of shoes or going
with a guy buying a house taking a job
should I should I should I when you have
to ask everybody else it means you don't
really know the answer fully yourself so
you get still be still and know
the answer will come nobody's journey is
seamless or smooth we all stumble we all
have setbacks if things go wrong you hit
a dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying time to
change course
so ask every failure this is what I do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time I say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson you
get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what I found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
Life's whisper
because life always Whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream whatever you resist persists but
if you ask the right question not why is
this happening but what is this here to
teach me what is this here to teach me
it puts you in the place and space to
get the lesson you need my friend
Eckhart Tolle who's written this
wonderful book called A New Earth
it's all about letting the awareness of
who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from The
Challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
Hennessey said I started this school
in Africa
and
I founded the school where I'm trying to
give South African girls a shot at a
future like yours Stanford
and I spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students I wanted every girl to feel her
worth reflected in her surroundings so I
checked every blueprint I picked every
pillow I was looking at the grout in
between the bricks I knew every thread
count of the sheets I chose every girl
from The Villages from nine provinces
and yet last fall I was faced with a
crisis I'd never anticipated I was told
that one of the dorm matrons was
suspected of sexual abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first I cried actually I sobbed for
about a half an hour and then I said
let's get to it that's all you get is a
half an hour you need to focus on the
now what you need to do now so I
contacted a child trauma specialist I
put together a team of investigators I
made sure the girls had counseling and
support and Gail and I got on a plane
and flew to South Africa and the whole
time I kept asking that question what is
this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been I got a lot of lessons I understand
now the mistakes I made because I had
been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
I built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out so it's a lesson that applies to all
of our Lives as a whole what matters
most is what's inside what matters most
is the sense of Integrity of quality and
Beauty I got that lesson and what I know
is is that the girls came away with
something too they've emerged from this
more resilient and knowing that their
voices have power empowerment is
Authority
it is a signed permission slip to
actually seize the day
it's the process of getting stronger and
more confident and more engaged and to
be empowered is to move through the
world without any kind of fear or any
kind of apology and with these gifts
comes in even deeper privilege I believe
and that is the ability to take charge
of your own life to own yourself and
claim your rights and here's what I know
for sure that to whom much is given much
is expected
and I have been given so much
I've earned it
I've been blessed with it
but I've been given a lot and that's why
I've chosen to use my life to lift other
people up I'm content I'm not just
relaxed I'm content because I know a lot
of rich people who are not happy
but I am not one of them
I want the happiest rich people you are
ever going to see
when you're trying to just when you're
trying to get away from it all and just
get away from everything you just relax
at one of your homes or yes I realize
well and also it doesn't take a lot for
me to relax I can uh I can be happy
looking at a leaf Kayla say what are you
sitting out under the trees what's your
thoughts and I'll say yeah I'm really I
could be happy with a book I can be
happy reading poetry I can be happy in
front of a fire I can be happy with my
dogs I can be yeah I'd like me up I
don't know thank you I have always known
this about celebrity
the real power of being somebody that
somebody knows and I really think that
the only difference between being famous
and not is that more people know your
name
so the only difference
between understanding that is
understanding that what Selma has done
what Susan has done what Anna has done
Rebecca has done what Jim has done what
I've done
you too can do
because true philanthropy comes from
living from the heart of yourself and
giving what you have been given
how will you do that how will you use
your personality the energy of your
personality to serve that which is your
Soul's Calling I know this for sure
any life no matter how fantastic it is
how glorious it seems how much attention
you receive how much square footage you
have any life and every life is enhanced
by the sharing and the giving and the
opening up of the heart space your life
gets better when you can find a way to
share it with someone else so what we've
done you can do the real empowerment
comes when every person leaves this room
and makes a decision
makes a decision
maybe that decision is that you will
write a check and support some of the
wonderful organizations you've heard
here today but the true decision is how
will you use yourself
how will you use everything that you
have been given to serve that which is
greater than yourself how will you use
that to become truly
authentically empowered now it is a
beautiful thing to receive an award and
to be on the cover of variety thank you
very much
it's a beautiful thing
but the true reward is in the lives that
you are able to touch and the people who
you know you have impacted how do I
define success
let me tell you money's pretty nice
I'm not going to stand up there and tell
you that it's not about money because
money is very nice
I like money
it's good for buying things
[Applause]
but having a lot of money does not
automatically make you a successful
person
what you want is money and meaning
you want your work to be meaningful
because meaning is what brings the real
richness to your life
what you really want
is to be surrounded by people you trust
and treasure and by people who cherish
you
that's when you're really rich Are you a
[Music]
wreck it is because I have lived in the
space of spirit my whole life my
favorite Bible verse because I am
Christian is acts something
I used to know the number but this is an
ax y'all can Google it
but it says thank you 1728.
in God I live and move and have my being
I live and move and have my being and
you want to know why I am really so
successful I knew that at four years old
I knew that when my grandmother said you
better watch me now because one day you
will have to learn how to wash these
clothes and hang them up like this so
and watch How I hold these clothes pins
in my mouth I want
[Applause]
and the reason I could do that is
because Spirit otherwise known as
intuition my instinct said
that's not going to be my life
so we all have that spiritual side and
this lesson tonight is about connecting
to it I believe that beneath the surface
of all physical problems is a spiritual
solution there is a spiritual solution
why because you are a spiritual being
having a human experience that's the
beginning of understanding spirituality
you are a spiritual being
having a human experience
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore I have a
dedicated Channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and I'll see you
there